je souhaite aussi promouvoir la justice
de la vie quotidienne dans beaucoup de
territoires
vous l'avez tout c'est tous constaté la
petite délinquance
les petites incivilités le tag
l'insultent le petit trafic
les troubles les troubles à ce que le
code de communal appelle la tranquillité
publique se sont développées au point de
gâcher la vie quotidienne des gens ils
se sont développés car faute de réponse
judiciaire
une forme d'impunité s'est installée et
elle s'est installée par manque de
reconnaissance et de moyens accordés par
l'état à l'autorité judiciaire dans lé
renforcement dans les renforcements que
je demanderai dès 2021 à la
représentation nationale de voter j'ai
demandé au garde des sceaux dans fléchés
pour créer dans les territoires des
juges de proximité spécialement affectés
à la répression de ces incivilités au
quotidien